I don't here's here's a very humbling
experience that I've sorry I guess
Epiphany that I've had recently that
because so many people hate me for
really no reason and it really made me
realize that like people only hate
somebody they're jealous of he sat back
and thought about it it was because I
was jealous of where that person was in
their life I felt like maybe they got an
opportunity that I should have gotten
that was a really really good
well-rounded answer I'm trying to wrap
my head around do you think people who
hate Osama Bin Laden are jealous of him
yeah that's the thing I right a perfect
response I can't even handle it I saw
one of the top comments on this clip
said her line was funnier than his whole
standup special it was very good we love
Tana um she is a friend of the show and
we honor her on this day and we say
thank you for the laugh